I do or should I say Avengers bringing
laughs to the big screen full rod in
Evangeline Lilly in the upcoming Marvel
movie ant-man and the wasp and honor is
exclusively on that set I have moments
where how did I get here
tell me you are filming I'm constantly
in motion there is barely room to
breathe
one thing helping Evangeline move was
that slick leather wasp suit which had
one important enhancement as I found out
on my set visit I don't have him I don't
have it so I had them give me a little
silly hipster
a little bit of a little lob right in
here and it feels so good you gave her
wings and blasters are you flexing right
now
fall on Evangeline partner up in the
movie and both of their suitable card
please do nobody's getting through these
abs of steel I'm telling you I can work
on them for months
the story has Rudd balancing being a
father with being a superhero just lucky
does in the real life that's pretty cool
having father who's playing honestly
when they come they only really seem
interested in craft service like that
they that you can get free Twizzlers and
you're like I can just go and get a
doughnut for Evangeline's young son it
was the high tech sets that were cool
was pressing all the buttons and he
turned back to his daddy said look dad
I've the watch might have been the best
moment of my life that is so cool maybe
a close second being the wasp herself
life is good
oh listen I'm out and still don't like
to drop it we get your point
we should how about the cast in this
film everybody ant-man and the wasp
buzzes in the theaters July 6
[Music]